el día anterior al regreso a clase para
robar y su hermano gemelo la cartuchera
cuaderno morral el programa de hoy
preparación de los útiles para la clase
de matemática
la equipa como todo parece listo para un
exitoso regreso a la escuela y aún así
son ya su madre está preocupada porque
rowan tiene problemas de audición y es
dis fãsico un trastorno poco conocido
que se manifiesta en dificultades de
expresión comprensión estas
discapacidades dificultan el proceso de
roban y tiene que compensarlas en la
escuela
cada año ha habido altibajos debido a la
comprensión de la disfagia a veces
asusta a la gente porque afecta el
lenguaje oral afecta a la escritura
hablamos mal escribe mal tiene
dificultades en la ortografía
dificultades en el uso de conjugaciones
es una ayuda específica para joven
porque hay colores al final del día y es
cierto que visualmente es muy fácil de
detectar con los colores
a pesar de estas dificultades y de las
repetidas peticiones de su madre en esta
víspera del reingreso del año escolar
roban todavía no tiene ninguna
información en cuanto a
las medidas que tomará su colegio para
adaptarse y así aliviar sus dificultades
por ejemplo con la presencia de un
acompañante especializado conocido como
abs escuela inclusiva para todos nos
damos cuenta de que no es el caso para
todos en términos absolutos no puede ir
a la escuela donde quiera ahora está en
sexto grado así que es la escuela media
se tomarán las medidas de adaptación va
a llegar a tiempo para que esta xxiii lo
recoja para ir a la logopedia va a tener
un abs por el momento no sabemos
mucha incertidumbre y una lucha diaria
que roban y sus padres comparten con
otras familias
este es el caso de la familia de janis
de 7 años a quien se le diagnóstico
autismo cuando tenía 3 años
logoterapeuta psicomotricista terapeuta
ocupacional hay algo que falta en la
apretada agenda del niño la escuela
falta de espacio en un instituto
especializado demasiado complicado de
manejar para un equipo educativo no
capacitado para responder a su
discapacidad ians ha estado fuera de la
escuela desde febrero
[Música]
no sabemos qué esperar de ella nos puede
ir muy bien y puede ser muy complicado
por lo que hay que saber adaptarse
proponer cosas diferentes
no
es absolutamente necesario que esté
acompañado que tenga un abc y que haya
un proyecto alrededor del niño para su
desarrollo cuando crezca será
indispensable
sé responsable
ha llegado septiembre janis todavía está
fuera del sistema escolar a pesar del
objetivo establecido en febrero por
emanuel macrón en la conferencia
nacional de discapacidad
como el community el primer objetivo es
que no haya ningún niño sin solución de
escolarización el próximo mes de
septiembre
sin solución escolar
janis aprende lo mejor que puede en casa
hay un tablero para él aquí todos los
días hace su calendario estamos
enseñando a contar por eso está
progresando un poco y creo que sí ya
misma estructuras especializadas puede
hacerlo ya tengo esperanza
cualquier familia que tenga preguntas y
es normal que las tenga al principio del
año escolar puede llamar a este número
08 05 80 51 10 y tendrán respuestas a
sus preguntas en 24 horas disculpe
es muy bueno lo que dijo pero todas las
familias que tienen un niño autista
deben ser seguidas eso es lo que deseo
para cada familia con un niño autista se
estudios web para que puedas salir
adelante y actualmente no hay datos para
estimar el número de niños en la
situación de janis por ello la unap y
asociación que representan a las
personas con discapacidad decidió reunir
testimonios en la plataforma en línea
imagen punto o hereje hay niños que no
están en la escuela a veces niños que
están en una escolarización demasiado
parcial
la idea es decirle al gobierno que
todavía en niño sin una solución
apropiada y con base a estos datos que
el gobierno pueda intervenir y que
podamos alcanzar nuestro objetivo de
cero niños sin soluciones de
escolarización
aprendemos a aceptar que nunca se acaba
que hasta el final de los estudios hay
que luchar y lo hacemos si sigue así no
debemos rendirnos de los 67 millones de
estudiantes que entraron al colegio en
2019 más de 360.000 eran discapacitados
hubo una mejora en varios años pero hay
una realidad la de los niños que siguen
sin ir al colegio